byrousa balk terrified moviegoers
everywhere with her spellbinding
performance in the craft
since then however she seems to have
dropped off the map
as it turns out she's been up to all
sorts of things since she played nancy
downs
bulk's first major acting credit comes
from the 1983 made for tv movie
the best christmas pageant ever she
quickly gained notoriety as a child
actor eventually becoming noticed by
disney
she was cast as dorothy gale in 1985's
return to oz
a fascinatingly twisted sequel to l
frank baum's
classic story it still holds up as an
unappreciated gem of disney's live
action catalog
though it surely traumatized many an 80s
child
whose parents thought it would be as
happy in a beat as the original
how twisted are we talking well bulk
dorothy goes through electroshock
therapy in a mental institution right at
the beginning of the film
don't even get us started on the
terrifying wheelers
after return to oz bulk was cast in a
1986 adaptation of the worst witch
and she appeared in several more tv
movies bulk's reputation was growing and
hollywood was taking notice
it wasn't long after return to oz that
bulk started receiving major dramatic
roles
in 1989 she appeared in valmond
alongside powerhouse actors like annette
benning
colin firth and meg tilly despite her
comparative inexperience
bulk more than holds her own against the
actors she shares the screen with
bulk then went on to other independent
work her performance as shade in 1992's
gas food lodging earned her an
independent spirit award for best female
lead
while her work as caroline fugate and
the tv miniseries murder in the
heartland
showed off the dark side that would make
her famous a few years later
paul hit the big time in 1996 when she
landed a lead role in teenage witchcraft
movie the craft
bulk's performance as stormy nancy downs
helped the craft achieve
major success and eventually status as a
cult classic
the film captures the moody and
disaffected style of the mid-1990s with
style
and particularly appeal to young women
of its era
it was the number one film of its
opening weekend despite minor marketing
and mixed reviews
run run back up to your room like
old coward that you
he's are pathetic
the craft follows a group of high school
girls who cope with their outcast status
with witchcraft
empowered by a mysterious deity known as
meno they use their newfound powers to
take revenge on those who have wronged
them
bulk's portrayal of nancy the ringleader
is the most memorable part of the film
a fiery misfit dealing with poverty and
an abusive stepfather
she combines genuine tragedy with a
terrifying mean streak
she is electric in every scene and a
huge part of the film's lasting legacy
the craft propelled bulk to new heights
of visibility and praise
and is remembered fondly today by fans
worldwide
after the craft balk entered the realm
of mainstream hollywood success
her crazed performance as coven leader
nancy swiftly saw her picked for another
intense
sadistic role the neo-nazi love interest
in american history x
balk played stacy ex-girlfriend to
edward norton's derrick and tony kaye's
intense
violent film here she displays the same
razor-sharp intensity she showed off in
the craft
albeit to very different tens the same
year she appeared in american history
x bulk also starred alongside adam
sandler and kathy bates in the waterboy
she plays a character with an edge
similar to previous roles in this film
but
the fact that her talents slide so
easily into a comedy
showed hollywood that bonk has a major
range
a variety of roles followed during this
period of bulk's career
including supporting parts in almost
famous and the island of dr moreau
she also did some voice acting in shows
like family guy and a few
early 2000s video games whenever we ask
what happened to a major star we expect
to hear about some legendarily
terrible film or a particularly awful pr
move that tanked their career
that isn't the case with farouza bulk
the way she explains it
she never felt right as a hollywood icon
so she decided to only tackle projects
she finds interesting in a 2013
interview with dread central
ball commented on her earlier career and
the stress she felt to constantly take
on more work
she eventually decided that the only way
for her to stay sane in hollywood and
enjoy acting
was to do it on her own terms she said
i'd rather only take on projects that i
want to not take everything that's
offered to me so i can be
more relevant just because farouza bulk
doesn't appear in dozens of movies per
year
doesn't mean she still isn't flexing her
creative muscles
she was born into an artistic family and
has carried on those traditions
as a visual artist bulk's work is
immensely varied
and it has been exhibited alongside
contemporary luminaries including mark
ryden and tara mcpherson
as a musician bulk is the front woman of
the group armed love militia
an eclectic group whose songs range from
hard driving rock to folk inflected
ballads
bulk has also inspired music made by
others emo puppet band fragile rock
performed farouza bulk
their ode to the actress as part of
their 2017 npr tiny desk concert
balk reportedly loved the tribute
though balk has branched out into
artistic pursuits beyond film
she still works regularly as an actress
in roles that strike a chord with her
on the movie front bulk is shied away
from mainstream film in favor of smaller
independent work
some of her more recent movies include
the 2018 horror movie hell is where the
home is
the 2017 thriller august falls and the
2015 war drama
battle scars bulk has also been active
on television most prominently she
enjoyed a seven episode run on the third
season of showtime's ray donovan is
ginger
a call girl trying to make ends meet
bulk is set to return to the world of
rock and roll with a supporting role in
paradise city
a spin-off of the film american satan
which explores a faustian bargain struck
from musical fame check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos but your favorite stars
are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you